LAURA: Thanks for coming.
And we're going to be recorded
this talk about we're also
streaming this to other offices.
And it's my pleasure to
introduce Dorothy Dankel who
is going to speak to us on how
to save the oceans with data.
It's my pleasure to
have her on here.
DOROTHY DANKEL: Thanks, Laura.
Thanks for the
invitation to come here.
I have some cool stuff
to show you guys.
And I'm looking forward
to see the reaction to it
because I have a
very ambitious title,
"How to Save the Ocean with
Integrated Assessments."
I think I first will
introduce myself a little bit.
I come from Indiana.
So I'm a Hoosier, but I've lived
the last 14 years in Norway.
I did my master's and Ph.D.
in Fisheries, Biology,
and Management at the
University of Bergen in Norway.
My husband's Norwegian,
and our two daughters
are Norwegian-Americans.
We're here in Boston.
We've been here the past year.
My husband has had a fellowship
at Joslin Diabetes Center.
In the last year,
I've been working
from home on my
Norwegian projects
and meeting up with as
many people in my network
as possible while I'm stateside.
And so now it's kind
of fun to be here.
I am a postdoc researcher
at the Institute
of Marine Research
in Bergen, Norway.
Bergen is on the west coast of
Norway in the fjord country.
And we're the best-funded
research institution in Norway.
So we've been doing science
there for over 100 years.
I'm also at the Center for
the Study of the Sciences
and the Humanities at the
University of Bergen--
I work there 30% at
the moment-- where
I work with philosophers,
anthropologists,
social scientists, on areas
of ethics and biotechnology
and these types of things.
So that's really fun
because I see a lot of ways
to apply that back to fisheries
and helping save our ocean.
I'm the chair of the European
working group Maritime Systems
the past three
years, and I'm also
a board member on the
Nordic Marine Think Tank.
So that's a handful
of affiliations,
which means that I
get a lot of ideas
from a lot of different places.
And it's really fun to
kind of put those together
for a common theme.
And that is saving the ocean.
The first question I
want to put forward
is one that I think most
people here could relate to.
What if we understood
interactions of humans
with ecosystems?
Humans and how they
interact with ecosystems
is something that is
kind of a broad topic.
When I was at Laura's
cabin in New Hampshire,
we started talking about
how Google uses that term
"ecosystem" and what
does that mean, and how,
as a biologist, how we
use that term "ecosystem."
Here's a graphic that our
Institute commissioned
which is showing the
Barents Sea ecosystem.
The Barents Sea is the sea
in the very north of Norway,
shared with Russia.
This is different
than the Bering Sea,
which is off the
coast of Alaska.
This is the Barents Sea.
And here you see
an idealized type
of picture of the ecosystem.
So you have, for
example, the polar bears
in the Arctic, the
big land mammals.
And then you have
the ocean mammals,
and then you have
the different species
of fish in the different
parts of the water column.
And here you have cod, the
Norwegian Northeast Atlantic
cod is the largest cod
stock in the world.
Last year, the fishing quota
was 2.2 billion pounds,
over a million metric tons,
which is a very different cod
stock than the ones found off
the coast of Georges Bank here,
which collapsed in the '90s and
hasn't really come back ever.
So we have plenty of
fish and lots of fish
that we harvest in Norway.
But the big question
is how we as humans
interact with these ecosystems.
When we talk about
ecosystems, we
can't forget about
the human connection
because humans are, in
exploited parts of the sea,
can be the biggest driver of
mortality in the ecosystems.
So what I'm going to
talk a little bit today
is I'm going to outline
the problem of how
to save the ocean, how to manage
the ocean sustainably and give
you a little bit of
background on that
and then start looking
for some solutions,
some bio-socioeconomic
models that I have quantified
for the Barents Sea,
the use of data,
and the potential
for collaboration
from government institutions
across from the politics
of governments and getting
in private foundations
and enterprises into the game.
The issue here is, how can we
sustainably manage the ocean?
And I'm going to go into
a little bit of philosophy
first because I think, in
order for us to really examine
the problem, it's
really nice when
we can look at people who
have really examined science
because that's what we're
talking about in the beginning.
So I don't know if people are
familiar with the Thomas Kuhn
cycle.
Thomas Kuhn is a
philosopher of science.
This book was
published in the 1962.
And this is the Kuhn
cycle of science.
And this is Science
with a big S,
a very generic view of science.
So this can be applied
to any part of science.
But when you start in the
normal science paradigm,
you start with science as a
puzzle-solving entity, right?
So you have problems
and you have puzzles
and you're trying to solve it.
In this paradigm cycle, you get
to what's called model drift.
And that's when you're less
able to solve problems using
the models and the
data that you have.
Getting into a little
bit of French philosophy,
Ivan Illich, who was
active in the 19th century,
has some interesting ideas
of why you would actually
get model drift.
There's two books that
I want to point out,
"Deschooling Society" and
"Tools for Conviviality,"
which is really interesting.
I'm just going to
put this problem
that he puts forth to you.
He starts out with the
institutionalization
of education.
We know this from centuries.
We've institutionalized
how we educate people.
Which gets into the
institutionalization society,
which gives power to
the technocratic elite.
This means that if
you go to a school
where you learn
certain techniques that
are used for
policy, for example,
this becomes a very
technocratic exercise.
Science becomes power.
Science becomes how
we make decisions.
And if you get that,
you can be stealing
the power of the citizens'
practical knowledge.
This becomes relevant
in resource management
because, in resource management,
we deal with stakeholders.
We deal with our fishermen.
We deal with the
producers on shore.
We deal with consumers.
And this is a example of
some Florida fishermen
who are protesting
some science coming
from NOAA in the
recreational fisheries.
They're protesting that it's
a very hierarchical system.
Their livelihoods are based
on the fishing quotas.
The fishing quotas are based
on the stock assessments.
And the stock
assessments can only
be run by these technocratic
elite scientists.
So this is an
interesting framing
of the problem of model drift.
So after model drift,
we get to model crisis
where we see that all of a
sudden our methods don't work.
In a fisheries
prospective, this has
been outlined in the literature.
Here's one article from
"Science" stemming the alarming
trends in the world's
fisheries demand
a fundamental change in
management and fishing
practices.
Another paper points to the
lack of an integrated solution
to the complexity in
managing world resources.
And we have not achieved
that integrated solution.
Of course, an
integrated solution
must be based on
integrated data.
There's really no
other way around that.
And so, then, the next
step is model revolution.
But there's a famous
fisheries biologist
in the University of Washington.
His name is Ray Hilborn.
And he points to the fact
that managing fisheries
is managing people, right?
We don't manage fish.
We manage fishermen.
And here he says that, I believe
rocket scientists have it easy.
The USA was able to
put a man on the moon
within a decade of
setting that goal.
Achieving biologically and
economically sustainable
fisheries has
proven more elusive.
He even alludes to the idea
of physics envy, right?
So physicists and
pure mathematicians--
they're able to have their
experiments with closed
variables and actually
run them and get results.
With ocean management
and fisheries,
we don't have that luxury.
We have to deal with not only
the vastness of the ocean
but the complexity of
the human dimension
because it's the
humans who are fishing
and the humans who are
running the models giving
the scientific advice.
So, in the Kuhn cycle, the
next step is model revolution.
And this happens when you
figure out what you really need.
In a fisheries perspective,
this is a systems view.
Now, there's three parts
of the fishery system.
This is from a book in 2012
by Tony Charles in Canada.
We're used to talking about
the natural ecosystem, about
our fish and our fishing quotas.
We're not used to talking about
how the natural ecosystem has
feedbacks with the
management system.
So when we set a
fishing quota and it's
implemented and the
politics of sharing
fishing quotas, the politics
of negotiating fishing quotas
and how that connects
to the human system.
So you have community,
consumers, households,
people who are eating fish,
people who are processing fish,
people who are fixing
boats that fishermen use.
This is all integrated.
And you can only
approach this when
you're talking about
interdisciplinary science.
Each of these three systems
has quantifiable data
that we can get.
And if you want to
look at fisheries
and manage the
oceans sustainably,
you must not forget
this complexity.
We're not going to
solve the sustainability
issues in our ocean
by only looking
at the natural ecosystem.
Which has been the status
quo the last 50 years.
So that's our model revolution.
You figure out what
you really need.
We need a systems view.
We need to incorporate the data
from different parts, not just
the biological system.
And then in the Kuhn
cycle in this book,
in 1962, "The Structure of
Scientific Revolutions,"
he talks about paradigm
change is the next step.
He's the one who coined
the term "paradigm shift."
You've probably heard of that.
And in order to get a
paradigm change in science,
you have to get some
sort of consensus.
And this is what
is kind of missing,
and this is what I want to
put forward as a missing link.
Let me just show
you this dichotomy
between normal science
and post-normal science
is the term I'm going
to introduce right now.
Normal science is what
I've just been alluding to.
This Thomas Kuhn's
definition-- puzzle-solving,
relatively routine
work of scientists,
experimenting within
a paradigm and never
really challenging
that paradigm.
They're just doing
their day-to-day work.
Whereas post-normal
science, by my colleagues
Silvio Funtowicz and
Jerry Ravetz-- Silvio
is still a professor.
He's been all over the
world, but now he's
landed in Bergen, which
is exciting for us.
And Jerry Ravetz,
who just retired.
In the early '90s,
they put forward this.
Post-normal science
is a methodology
of inquiry for cases
where facts are uncertain,
values are in dispute,
stakes are high,
and decisions are urgent.
Now, the poster
child for post-normal
is climate science, right?
You have very uncertain
models, uncertain predictions,
at the same time,
values are in dispute.
Who is going to pay?
for example.
The stakes are high, and
the decisions are urgent.
We must make decisions
today if we're
going to get on a
sustainable path.
But since values are
embedded in science,
post-normal science should
integrate stakeholders
in an extended peer community.
The extended peer
community means
that sometimes the
questions scientists
are asked when having
to advise policy
are not scientific questions.
They're questions
based on values,
based on the
objectives for society.
And this is the
post-normal paradigm.
This is where you have
to get different people
around the same table
to discuss this.
So in this diagram, you have, on
the x-axis, systems uncertainty
from low to high and
decision stakes on the y-axis
from low to high.
And that green area in the
bottom left-hand corner
is where you have
applied science.
This is the physics envy,
where you have low systems
uncertainty but the decision
stakes are very big.
Professional consultancy
is the next level,
and post-normal science is this
area where systems uncertainty
is high as well as
the decision stakes.
OK.
So now I've introduced the
idea of post-normal science
and maybe you think,
OK, that could be right.
But what does it
actually look like?
Can you put it into pictures?
Normal science a la
Kuhn is this poor woman
under all her papers,
this academic.
It's mono-disciplinary,
technocratic, certain,
and predictive.
Whereas post-normal science
is academic and social,
trans-disciplinary,
participative, uncertain,
and exploratory.
And you have people around
the table, different experts
from different disciplines,
also including the stakeholders
and politicians.
So perhaps one of the reasons
that we've had so much trouble
managing our natural renewable
resources and climate change,
for example, is that it's hard
for us to admit that science
cannot give us the one answer.
Even if we had all the
best data in the world,
we still have values and other
social concerns at stake.
Which are not necessarily
scientific questions.
OK.
So I gave you a little
bit of background.
And I'm going to now focus
more specifically on oceans.
And here are some illustrations
by my friend and colleague
Mariano [INAUDIBLE], who's
at the University of Valencia
in Spain, to kind of illustrate
the problems that we have
from an ocean and
fisheries perspective.
So this is a music box.
And one thing that we learn from
studying ecosystems and giving
ecosystem-based
advice is the whole
is greater than the
sum of the parts.
And I put the whole
as a capital W.
And when I talk about the
Ocean, I use a capital O.
And this is because
this is one word that's
encompassing very many things.
And a music box, you can
break it down to its parts.
But you can never
necessarily guess
from its parts, when you
turn the crank and the music
comes out, how that affects
you as a person, what joys,
or what turmoils, or
everything that you
get from that music, kind of
illustrating that the whole is
greater than the
sum of the parts.
Now, here's our history lesson.
We're going to go all the way
back to the French Revolution.
And this train of thought
is coming from the professor
emeritus at Harvard EO Wilson.
I don't know if
you've heard of him.
He's still living.
He's approaching 90.
He has a book from 1998
called "Consilience
the Unity of Knowledge."
And he explains in the
introduction of the book
that we can really blame a
lot of our scientific problems
on the French Revolution.
And let me quickly
explained that.
Before the French Revolution,
you had a monarchy, right?
All the different
scientists in the kingdom
were reporting to
one person, the king.
So if the king had a grand
challenge or a problem
or something that he
wanted to fix or find out.
For example, I want
to have the best
wine in all of the kingdoms.
So he would put his
biologists, his scientists,
his philosophers,
his economists all at
work for that one
single purpose.
And so the biologists would have
to make the perfect vineyards.
The economists would
have to figure out
how to do it efficiently
to scale it up.
The philosophers would have
to think, what makes the best
wine? and all those
types of things.
But at the end of the day, they
were reporting to one person.
So it was a unity of knowledge.
After the French Revolution,
they cut the king's head off,
cut Marie Antoinette's head off.
And now the political
system is more democratic.
It's more flat.
It's not this top-down,
hierarchical system.
And the disciplines in science
became very disciplined,
which was great because we
had a huge advances in math,
and biology, genetics, all
these different things.
But in the 21st century,
we're still thinking, OK,
that's great that we know
how to sequence DNA and do
all this stuff.
Great.
Where's the cure for cancer?
How are we going to get there?
Because what we know
is the grand challenges
that we have today in
society-- climate change
and all of these things--
is not up to one discipline.
You must have a
unity of knowledge.
So after the French
Revolution, the disciplines
separated from the whole.
And we got a very
disciplined view of science.
Here's a picture of
a fisherman looking
through a little peephole
as an illustration
that the ocean is very vast.
If we just use biology
in our limited views
of how we can look
at the ocean, we're
not getting the whole system.
We're too disciplined.
And this leads us to very
confused and frustrated
decision-makers.
Here you have a
decision-maker who
has three different
scientists telling him
three different things.
Three different sources of data.
What's going on?
The decision-maker
then makes a decision
based on the stakeholder or the
scientist who yells the loudest
or whom he trusts the most.
And we get politics
not necessarily based
on a collective view of science.
So there's a call for
consilience of knowledge, which
means unity of knowledge,
moving towards interdisciplinary
and systems view of the whole.
This is the picture
post-normal science.
This is where you have your
biologists, your politician,
your philosopher, your
fisherman, your economists all
around the same table.
It's a very iterative process.
Many, many meetings.
The thing is that the
system has to be driven,
that everybody is in
on this game of getting
together and talking
and talking and talking
and talking and discussing
how we put these together,
what data is useful for
us, and all these things.
OK.
Let's get a little
bit towards solutions.
I think it's important
to have this idea that,
OK, if there's a
will, there's a way.
We have tons of data.
If there's one thing that we
do well it's collect data.
I'm going to show you some
examples of the type of data
that we collect in fisheries
and ocean management.
But it's very
important that we have
this idea of the
focus imaginarius.
The 18th century
philosopher Immanuel Kant
describes the focus
imaginarius as such.
It is something that you know
very well what it looks like.
It's the perfect picture.
It's the perfect ocean
managed perfectly.
Everybody's perfectly happy.
It's what you can imagine could
happen, and it's your focus.
You're not naive to think that
you're ever going to get there,
but you must have some
sort of goal to go towards.
So I'm going to show you
three steps on will and way.
So as will gets higher
and way gets higher,
you get closer to your
focus imaginarius.
So first let's talk
about status quo.
What do we do today when we
are giving fishing advice
and managing the ocean?
This is taken from ICES.
So it's I-C-E-S. It stands
for the International Council
for the Exploration of the Sea.
ICES is the world's oldest
intergovernmental organization.
It's over 100 years old
and collects all the data
in Europe, with
some collaboration
with Canada and
the United States.
Does the science, does
the stock assessments
to give the fishing advice.
Now, there is no real
will, political will
for an integrated assessment.
The politicians don't know how
they would use it, basically.
So ICES keeps doing status
quo, single stock assessment
and derives their advice.
This is the popularized
sheet that they give out
for each stock.
There's a lot more sheets.
The whole assessment
working group report
could be from 100
to 200 pages long,
but they give this sheet
as a popularized version.
This is for cod
in the North Sea.
For 2014, the advice was that,
based on the EU Norway Plan,
the landings in 2014 should be
no more than 28,809 tons, which
happens to be 9% less than the
2013 total allowable catch.
OK.
What does this mean?
28,809 tons.
Here we have five
significant digits.
So you might think that the
science of stock assessment
is really quite certain.
OK.
Well, they really know
what they're talking about.
For one year, they can
fish that much and this
is going to result in
sustainable fishing.
The fact of the matter is this
is very, very sloppy work on
how we give advice.
There's no way we
could ever have
five significant
digits of certainty.
I call it sloppy, but
this is just routine.
This is how they've been
doing it for 20 years.
This is what the
policy makers expect.
This has been negotiated.
This is what is done.
That's a basis of
a whole other talk
that I just gave at [INAUDIBLE].
So I'm starting to do
something about this.
But first we have to be serious
about what science can give us
and what science can't give us.
Science can't give
us that certainty.
And we have to be honest
with our policy makers
on what science
can do and not do.
It's part of the
Occupy Science Movement
that I allude to a
little bit later.
OK.
So getting a little
bit more will
to do an integrated assessment
and a little bit combining
more data sources.
I have this paper from 2009.
You might actually
recognize this map.
So here we are in Cambridge.
And here off the coast of
Massachusetts and Cape Cod
is Georges Bank.
Maybe you have heard
of Georges Bank.
Used to be one of the
most productive fishing
areas in the world.
People have been fishing
there for over 1,000 years.
In Georges Bank, you have a
really interesting dynamic
at the current moment right now.
I have overlaid this map on
some of the data from NOAA.
I'm just going to explain
the axes really quickly.
The x-axis here is your biomass.
This is the data
from 2007, and this
is over the biomass at
maximum sustainable yield.
MSY is our term there.
So basically from zero to a lot.
And on the y-axis, our
fishing mortality rate.
This is how much fishing is
happening in proportion, where
you have zero fishing
here and a lot.
So in this area where
it's red, the fish
that are plotted-- each
of these little dots
is a fish stock from
Georges Bank-- in this area,
the fish plotted
here are overfished
and overfishing is occurring.
Whereas down here where
you have a lot of biomass
and not a lot of
fishing happening,
these stocks are not
overfishing and overfishing
is not occurring.
So what you have here
on Georges Bank--
you have Georges
Bank haddock here.
This is what it looks like.
You have a lot, a surplus.
We still have a surplus on
Georges Bank of haddock,
but Georges Bank
cod and yellow tail
flounder are overfished and
overfishing is occurring.
Which means the fishermen want
to target haddock and leave
the cod and yellowtail to be.
However, they cannot do
this because the technology,
the gear technology, when
they're dragging the Otter
trawl, the net, along the sea
bottom and destroying a lot
of habitat in their wake,
they're catching cod and yellow
tail as a by-catch of haddock.
They cannot only target haddock
until relatively recently.
And let me just explain.
This is why I wanted to have
a mic that moves because this
is where I get to use
my hands a little bit.
This is where biology comes.
When the trawl-- this is
the trawl, the net-- when
it's being dragged
along the sea floor,
the reaction, the biological
reaction, for haddock
is to swim up.
It doesn't want
to go in the net.
They're not that dumb.
And it swims up.
Whereas the cod and the yellow
tail swim down along the floor.
These are all bottom creatures.
So some fishermen and some
scientists got this good idea
and they created the Ruhle
trawl, which is basically
the same thing as
an Otter trawl,
but they just lift it one
yard off the bottom of the sea
floor.
That way, as the net is
coming-- and then it's
not being dragged
along the sea floor
as they usually are-- the
cod and the yellow tail
will dive down and haddock
will dive up and be caught.
So you can catch them.
And this is really
interesting where
you can use gear technology
from an ecological perspective
and from an economic
perspective.
We want to target the haddock.
There's also this
separator trawl
which does essentially
the same thing.
The cod and the yellow
tail flounder go down here
and they go outside the net.
Whereas the haddock,
they go up and they
get into what we call the cod
end, the part of the net where
they're caught.
So I wanted to do an
analysis for the fishermen
because they were
skeptical about changing
their gear to the Rhule trawl.
They didn't know how
it was going to work.
They didn't know
if they're going
to get their yields
and their money.
So we put together the
biological data and the stock
assessments we had
for all nine stocks
that we have data
for in Georges Bank.
And we have the profitability
surveys and the economic data
from some of the
economists at NOAA.
And we can show these
trade-offs, right?
Because unless we have
the biological data
and the employment data and
the economic data together,
we can't coherently show
trade-offs to the policymakers.
So here are the
three different lines
of the three different trawls.
I won't go into so many details
but the point of the matter
is here, where you're getting
lots of yield and lots
of producer surplus, which
is a proxy for profit,
you have the trade-off of
the different other stocks.
These are the mixed species of
the by-catch stocks going down.
And so we can look at different
amount of days at sea.
For example, we can
look at status quo
and see the results
on the economic,
the results on employment, and
the results to the ecosystem.
This is just an example
of what could be done.
I took this paper to the
Massachusetts State House
in 2009 to State
Senator Bruce Tarr
who said, oh, it's great that
you scientists are actually
using those socioeconomic
assessments that NOAA always
does but it's never combined
with the biological ones.
So there's a little
bit of work there,
but we can go a
little bit further.
This is some work that I'm
in the process of where we're
trying to look at
stakeholder conflicts
because a large
amount of stakeholders
are interested in fisheries.
And how do we find the
management strategy
that is going to satisfy the
most amount of stakeholders?
That's a very, very
interesting question.
Very little work is done that
usually quantifies utility
functions for stakeholders
for [INAUDIBLE] so this
is some work that
we've pioneered.
These are examples
of stakeholders.
Up here, you have your
industrial fisherman.
You have two different
representatives of society.
This is from a
Norwegian context where
we have the Norwegian
fisheries minister who
was from the right
party, who wanted
profitable fisheries,
big boats, kind
of this profit-centered
rhetoric.
And after him was the
first female fisheries
minister in Norway.
She was representing
a lot of minorities
at the same time when she was
appointed fisheries minister
from the Labor Party.
She was not only the
first woman there.
She was of Sami dissent,
from the Lapland country
in the north of Norway
and she was pregnant.
So that was cool.
And her political philosophy
was that all of Norway,
which has one of the largest
coastlines in the world,
should be lit up with
fishing villages.
We want to put an emphasis
on employing people,
the cultural value of
fisheries and whatnot.
And then you have
environmentalists
like Maren Esmark
at WWF in Oslo who
has different utility
coming out of the fishery.
And then you have your
small-scale coastal fisherman,
your artisanal fisherman.
And what's coming
out of the fishery
are what we call utility
components like yield,
profit, employment at
sea, employment at shore,
and ecosystem preservation
also has value coming out
of the fishery.
And, basically, you can
make a utility function
on how strong are
the preferences
for each stakeholder on
these different components
that we can get out.
And then you would
quantify what we
call the area of
joint satisfaction.
So let's say this
is a generic showing
the results for stakeholder
A for different management
strategies.
And in this blue zone, they
would be getting, for example,
90% of their maximum utility.
So they're pretty
happy in that area.
Stakeholder B would be
getting, for example,
90% in this area and then
just simply overlap them
and talk about an area of where
you can start the negotiations.
So you are already starting
with some sort of a consensus.
This is avoiding where
you're starting from scratch
and people are just going
to butt heads and not agree.
So this is what
we've quantified.
We call it the assessment of
joint stakeholder satisfaction,
where we combine the data from
the different data sources,
from the biology and from the
employment and economic model.
And then we integrate
utility components,
get stakeholder
specific total utility,
and then get what we call the
JSS, the Joint Stakeholder
Satisfaction.
This is not routinely done.
This is important to realize
because we don't even
do integrated assessments
on this scale.
There's scientists
around the world that
are getting their fingers
wet and starting to do it,
but we definitely don't do it on
a large political scale, which
is needed.
This is the one result I'm
going to show you from this.
We did this-- quantified it
for Barents Sea Capelin, which
is a small pelagic
fish that's sold
on the Japanese market
for human consumption.
This is a schooling fish
and we did it for cod,
North Atlantic cod, which is a
much bigger, longer-lived fish,
to see if there
were differences.
I'm going to break
it down because this
is a pretty heavy figure.
On the x-axis, we have
harvest proportion,
from zero to almost
100 percent fishing.
And now we're doing this in
a computer simulation model,
so we can actually do all
parameter space and look at it.
And on the y-axis, you have
the minimum size of capture.
So you guys are probably
familiar that-- if you're
recreational fishing
and your fish is smaller
than the minimum size,
you have to throw it back.
So now we're simulating minimum
size of the whole spectrum
for capelin, which
only gets to be
about 18 centimeters
and cod, which
gets to be about this big.
For each data point,
each combination
of harvest proportion--
for example,
say you have 20% harvest
proportion and two centimeters
minimum size-- that
represents a strategy.
So you would fish this amount,
and you wouldn't fish them
until they're this big.
For each of these
management strategies,
all five stakeholders
have their utility value.
How much utility from
their utility function
are they getting
with that strategy?
And now we are getting into
a little bit of philosophy.
We're not going to plot all
five of those stakeholders
because, if we follow the
maxi-min principle by John
Rawls who was a famous 20th
century philosopher-- he said
the measure of a society
is how they take care
of the least-advantaged
citizen, right?
Which is a really
nice philosophy.
I think a lot of people
can agree on that.
So in that case,
we have the results
of the five stakeholders.
We only plot the stakeholder
who does the worst.
We assume that we
want to take care
of that stakeholder
looking for the consensus.
We're concerned
when everybody is
happy, not just two or
three people or one person.
So this star represents where
all the stakeholders receive
their maximum utility based on
the weakest link, basically.
Which shows that we're fishing
a lot but at very large sizes
because these circles
represent the status quo.
Where we manage
fisheries today for cod.
We manage them around
38% harvest proportion,
and the minimum size
is 45 centimeters.
This is really interesting.
It's hard to know
how much trust--
I've done a lot of
uncertainty analyses on this.
And we're still doing this.
The fact of the matter is we
get very different results.
The status quo
management is based
on the biological assessment.
This star is based on the
bio-socioeconomic assessment,
including stakeholder value, so
what they value in the fishery.
This is giving us
different results,
which I think means that we
need to look closer at this
because perhaps we're
not even managing to what
the majority of
stakeholders actually want.
Right?
This is a post-normal question.
We have to get people around
the table using the philosopher
Mary Parker Follett, who is
my favorite philosopher-- you
should Google her.
She's really, really cool-
she was born and raised
in Massachusetts
in the late 1800s
and did a lot of political
management theory
and how to resolve conflicts.
She says that, unless you
have diverse stakeholders
around the table and they get
to reevaluate their objectives--
so you have one
iteration of stakeholders
and they say what they want.
And then you do
that again and again
and again until
they can realize,
where is the integrated
solution going to come from?
It has to come from us.
How is it going to get there?
So this is all towards the area
of the focus imaginarius, where
we want to be.
We have to start making
small steps to get there.
So that's some work
that I have done
and, I want to put it
also in a little bit
different perspective as well.
Let me kind of sum up
before I go to the part
where I show you
some cool data stuff.
This is kind of part of
the Occupy Science movement
because I find a lot of
the scientific ethos being
very important here.
So I'm a biologist
and I collect data,
but I understand that the
employment data in the fishery
is really quite important.
I understand the power
of the policymakers
to put forward science.
So I want to put this forward
as, how can we save the Ocean?
Unless we educate
our students to see
the Whole, the Whole
with the big W,
they'll never understand
how their discipline,
how their knowledge fits
into the whole, right?
So this is getting
a little bit back,
bridging the gap that we got
from the French Revolution.
It's very good to have
disciplined scientists.
That's great.
This is technology.
This is advancement.
But we can't do that to the
expense of the grand challenges
that we have-- climate change,
renewable resource management.
Once they understand how
they fit into the whole,
you can have cooperation
among disciplines
to understand the whole and then
to use the data in integrated
platforms in an extended peer
community-- this is relating
to post-normal
science-- to inform
science-driven policy not
policy-driven science.
Again, this is a little bit of
the Occupy Science movement,
where you have to stand
up for what science can do
and what it can't do and
actually look at that.
OK.
This is the last part where I
come with some brainstorming
ideas that me and my
colleagues in Bergen--
and actually I had
colleagues from all
over the world that
had some ideas here.
How could Google
help save the Ocean?
What do we do with data now?
This is the dnanexus.com project
that Google Ventures heavily
invested in.
This is really
quite fascinating.
So this is basically
putting all the data
that we have on DNA
sequencing up in the cloud
so people can access it, look
for new clues in the DNA,
look for new-- if you're looking
for personalized medicine,
all this type of thing.
Where you have all
these public databases
of data going into
the DNA Nexus cloud.
Their office is
in Mountain View,
so there's probably some people
who have maybe heard of this.
So basically you're putting
everything up in the cloud,
and you can use your
research community,
for example, your biologists,
your statisticians,
other collaborators, to
combine all of this data,
look at different
analyses and get results
that you couldn't have gotten
otherwise through a network.
It's fascinating.
It's really easy to see
how you would apply this
to fish and oceans because
we only have one Ocean.
That's why I have
Ocean with a capital O.
And so everything is
inherently interconnected.
We must remember that.
This is an example
I was referring
to ICES, the
International Council
for the Exploration of the Sea.
There's over 1,600 scientists
that routinely, every year,
meet in working groups.
This is an overview of some
of the data that they have.
For example, they have
almost 700,000 measurements
from the biological
community over 34 years.
You have from the-- sorry.
From the oceanographic data,
you have 245 million data points
over 122 years.
So we collect a lot of data
that's all publicly available.
WWF has been doing
something really interesting
in the Arctic.
So this is a map of the Arctic.
So here's Greenland.
This is the eastern
coast of North America.
And here's Iceland.
Here's some data that they have.
For example, you click
on a fish that you want,
and this data is
actually showing
all species and the relative
probabilities of occurrence
in these areas.
And so you have a
lot of different data
that's kind of
overlayered each other.
It's interesting.
It's, for me, kind of
a toy to look around.
It's not very, very
scientific, especially when
you're talking about relative
probabilities, blah, blah,
blah.
But you can do it during
different seasons and all
these things.
And you can get a picture
of the fish that you want.
It's really cool,
and it's showing
that, unless we can
start mapping the Arctic,
we can't really divvy
it up politically.
We can't really study it.
It's become a very big
political issue, for example,
between Canada, USA,
Norway, and Russia.
Who is going to own
these shipping lanes that
are freeing up with the ice?
Here's a paper that my
colleague, Nils Olav Handegard,
published a couple
years ago, talking
about how we're collecting data.
This is a really cool thing that
the technology is there now.
When we're at sea-- this is
our research boat, GO Sars.
It's the world's most
advanced research vessel
at my Institute of Marine
Research in Norway.
We can see below, using acoustic
methods, what fish are there.
And we can sample them.
So we can match up
our acoustic sampling
with the actual sample.
For example, we can put these
sounders on cruise ships.
So whenever they're going back
and forth for wherever they're
going around the
world they can also
be picking up continuous data.
But Nils Olav has pioneered--
we have these missiles that they
have in California,
which is really cool.
They cost a lot.
They're multi-million
dollar little things,
but you can shoot
them in the ocean,
and they just are
collecting data all over.
There's people that spend
their whole careers on this.
I'm not doing it
that much justice.
But one thing that
Nils Olav has done
are these sounders that are in
the sea bed of the floor that
are collecting data 24/7,
data like salinity, turbidity,
but also fish acoustics,
what schools are passing,
species identification.
The thing that is
bad about the ships
is that the fish avoid
the ship's, right?
They don't want
to get near them.
They're loud.
They're clunky, and they know
they're going to get caught.
Whereas if you have these
passive data collectors,
this is a really
good way to do it.
The problem being, once we get
this data, how do we share it?
Where's a common platform?
We're really going
at collecting data.
We're really bad about
sharing it and knowing
how do we integrate it.
So the Norwegian public
has paid for this.
Why should they share it
with the rest of the world.
So that's what we're
really missing is
a common platform and people
who understand these data
platforms.
This is the last data
thing I want to show you.
This is really cool data.
This is, again, coming from WWF.
This is data coming from
a single bluefin tuna.
Bluefin tuna is the iconic
species, for me, of the Ocean.
It's my favorite fish.
It spawns in the Mediterranean,
crosses the Atlantic
to the Caribbean
to start feeding up
the eastern seaboard,
crosses again,
and it's now up in Norway again.
It has been an endangered
species for a while.
Now, it has rebounded, partly
because of political measures,
finally.
They have stopped a
lot of the overfishing.
So pretty soon it
might be OK again
to eat bluefin tuna,
which is really cool.
Anyway, bluefin tuna
is a fantastic swimmer.
This is where they tagged--
so you can tag them.
You can shoot a little
tag in its back.
Kind of like I guess in Jaws
where they shoot a harpoon,
but this is-- you just
shoot it like a dart.
And this is in
the Mediterranean,
Palma de Mallorca, off
the coast of Spain.
And you start getting
all these pings
about where it's actually going.
And this red spot is
where it popped off.
So this was data from, I
think, seven or eight days.
And you can do this.
There's all these
other cool things
that you can do with the
data, the crux of it being,
OK, where do we put the data?
How do we access it?
How do we make sure the right
people get access to this data
to actually do something
meaningful with it?
So if we go back
to our issue, how
can we sustainably
manage the Ocean?
I put forward the power of
data and the power of getting
an extended peer community
around the table to not just
talk about data but also
to talk about values
because there's a difference
between science for science
and science for policy,
occupying science so we know
what science can actually
give us and what it can't.
And I would open up
the floor if anybody
has any questions or comments.
And looking forward to
hearing what you think.
Thanks a lot.
[APPLAUSE]
Is there anything
that was unclear?
I could reiterate.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question about that one
chart that you showed with the
cod and another kind of fish
and you had the
star and the circle.
The circle was what
the current fishing is
and the star-- that
was to represent
what would satisfy
all stakeholders?
And one thing I
didn't understand--
so it was looking for basically
harvesting bigger fish.
And I didn't quite
understand how
that would satisfy
more stakeholders.
DOROTHY DANKEL: Yeah, that
satisfies most stakeholders
because the bigger the fish,
the more profit you receive.
The bigger the fish,
the more you're
waiting to fish
until they get big,
which is preserving
the ecosystem.
AUDIENCE: Does that
satisfy fishermen
because that [INAUDIBLE]
means they would have to fish
less now to wait for
these fish to get bigger.
DOROTHY DANKEL: So there's a
different temporal time scales
here, and there's
also the investment.
So they've made
major investments
to fish them at the current
size because to buy new nets
and to change the net size
is a very large investment.
So that shows that, in
this idealized world where
they put preference on
profit, a little bit more
in the industrial fishermen,
putting a little bit
more preference on profit
than yield because there's
a difference between
profit and catch.
Because you can
get a lot of catch,
but you could have used almost
all your resources to catch
that catch.
And the selling
price will be lower
than what you actually put in.
So if you focus on
profit, usually you
have maximum profit before
you have maximum yield.
So then if you focus on profit,
you're focusing on size.
Especially if you talk about
tuna on the Japanese market,
a bluefin tuna like this
is not worth anything.
A bluefin tuna that's two meters
long could be worth $1 million.
So there's a lot
of these dynamics
that, until you start
modeling it and looking
at the trade-offs,
you don't really
understand behavioral patterns.
But if they put their
behavior and they want profit,
you get different results
than if they want yield.
It's different for each fishery.
But in this case,
that was the case.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Did say something
about the difference
between going around
and figuring out
what everyone's interests are
and then doing all of this work
to figure out what would be the
best thing versus getting them
together to listen to each other
and figuring it out together?
DOROTHY DANKEL: Yeah,
there's a big difference.
So the philosopher I
mentioned, Mary Parker Follett,
who I just think
is cool, she says
that there's very different
psychological behaviors that
are going on.
If I'm a scientist, if I go to
everybody's office by myself
and say, OK, what do you want?
Fill out this questionnaire?
What do you want in the fishery?
And I go to 20
different stakeholders
and do that, combine that,
then I do the simulations,
and I say, OK, this is
what you guys wanted.
They see the results.
They might say, eh, no I
didn't really mean that.
In climate change
science, there's
a big difference between the
preferences that they state,
their stated preferences and
their revealed preferences.
So I might say that I'm all
for helping climate change,
but at the end of the day,
I'm still buying my tickets
to San Francisco for
a three-day vacation
because my revealed
preference is actually
different than what I state.
So it's important, she says,
to get people around the table
and give them a chance to
reevaluate their positions
according to the
positions of other people.
So you get different
fishermen and say, OK,
what do you want
out of the fishery?
He says, I want to
catch a lot of fish.
The next fisherman,
you ask him, he says,
I want a 10% profit margin.
And then the guy next to him
is like, oh, that sounds good.
I think I want that too.
Right?
And then he's like,
so, as a scientist,
what's the difference
between maximum yield
and 10% profit
margin in my fishery?
And I say actually
you would catch less.
You would have more vacation.
You would have more money.
And then, all of a sudden, if
he had not been in the room
when the other people
stated their preferences,
he wouldn't see
different options.
And you can't look for
integrated solutions
unless those people are
there at the same time.
AUDIENCE: So how do
you get them together?
DOROTHY DANKEL: You get them
together through, for example,
research projects.
We have research
projects where we
have stakeholder
consultation and stakeholder
workshop, stakeholder
framing meetings.
This has become really a la
mode in Europe at the moment.
So I have a lot
of colleagues that
get-- the European Commission is
paying for this type of science
to be done.
We still have to make the
bridge to actual politics
and actual decision-making based
on these type of workshops.
We're not there yet because
at the end of the day,
it's still some
people in Brussels
who are going to decide
what the fishing quota is
and they do this
behind closed doors.
So we have to get the show,
the methodology, in practice
and really push hard for that.
That's, I think, the
way you have to go.
AUDIENCE: So how do you weight
stakeholders, some of whom
are more important that others?
The recreational fishermen
or the [INAUDIBLE].
DOROTHY DANKEL: Yeah, so
this is a big question.
This is where you go.
I mean, this is a question
for political science,
for anthropologists,
social scientists,
who gets to sit at
the table, right?
Because that's a big
commitment to sit at the table
because if it's an
iterative process,
you have to have the funds
to actually be there.
You have to have knowledge
to actually participate.
And it's a time and an
economic commitment.
There's not one answer.
It depends on the fishery.
And, again, this is
a political question.
Science can help.
So science can, for
example-- social scientists
can say who the main players
have been the last 10
years based on their attendance
at different meetings,
their profits coming from the
fishery, how many people they
employee in the fishery,
and these types of things.
But usually what's
done in Europe--
we have the regional
advisory counsels,
which is the meeting
of the stakeholders
for the different
regions of Europe.
They are I sign
up, and what we see
is there's an overflow
of industrial fishermen
and fisherman representatives
and not very many
conservationists because
they're spread thin.
They can't send
somebody to Copenhagen
every six weeks to
have the meeting.
So you don't see a
real democracy there.
It's still the
people with the money
who are participating
in the stakeholder.
So that's a question
for democracy
actually, as it should be.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So in
that chart that you
showed where the star was
on the optimal fishing.
That was 100% take
at a certain size.
Is that in any way practical?
DOROTHY DANKEL:
It's not quite 100%
because-- the practicalities are
really disputable about that.
It depends on the fishery.
First of all, it
would take-- this
is when you talk
about paradigm change.
For the fishermen to wait until
the cod is this big to catch,
it's not even on
the radar, right?
They mature when
they're about this big.
Science has shown that there's
tendencies for-- we're actually
seeing the fish evolve
in front of our eyes.
In the last 40
years, cod has been
maturing at nine years of age.
And now, because the
fishing mortality
is many more times
the natural mortality,
they're spawning
sooner because they
know that they're
going to get caught.
So now they're
spawning at five, six.
So they're shrinking.
It's a shrinking fish.
This has ethical
considerations too
because we're changing their
biology because of the fishing
pressure.
So it's not really on
the fishermen's radar
to wait until they're this
big, even though, ecologically,
and from a profit
standpoint, it could-- so,
I mean, the practicalities
are up to debate.
I presented this to
200 Norwegian fisherman
and it wasn't
really on the radar.
They understand the concept.
And, again, that result.
I don't put much trust
in that result, per se.
We would have to do many more
different types of analysis
to get some real
certainty of that, OK,
can we trust this
somewhat or not.
The fact of the matter is
that we have all the data.
We just have to do
it, and this is just
showing an outline of how you
can incorporate stakeholder
utility functions and
look for strategies
that satisfy as many people.
So the practicalities
are up to the fishermen
and what they're
willing to change
and policymakers because,
at the end of the day,
they have to put
objectives on the table.
What are they actually
trying to achieve
if they're going for
profitability, then,
OK, we can show those trade-offs
for the other systems.
But having a framework
where you can
show trade-offs is
of utmost importance
because that's what you have
to do, at the end of the day,
is to make some decisions.
Thanks a lot for having me.
[APPLAUSE]